my path in voiceover was very
non-traditional I actually have a degree
in business and a degree in Spanish and
parlayed that into working in the
Silicon Valley in California for ten
years working in all manner of startups
venture capital and and going to their
startup companies in building a company
from for people to hundreds and and on
and on and really struggling to enjoy
life so serendipitously I was I was out
with my husband and we were talking
about dream jobs and I said I'd always
wanted to be a voice on The Simpsons and
two weeks later I was getting ready for
work one of those fateful mornings and
Nancy Cartwright who is the voice of
Bart Simpson was on the radio to promote
the movie and started talking about
voice-over and how it was this
incredible job and we in the San
Francisco Bay Area had a school right
nearby that was incredible and I called
that day and I started taking classes
that week and two years later I had an
agent and I quit my job and moved to Los
Angeles and here we are today my first
job was as Katya in The Walking Dead
which was incredible you know it was a
round of auditions that came through my
agent in San Francisco I auditioned for
Clementine I ocean for Lily I auditioned
for Carly but there was something about
Katya that spoke to me but she required
a Belgian accent so I went out and I
researched Belgian as much as I could
and I had a Belgian friend and I
followed him around with a tape recorder
for two days and I'm sure he thought I
was a psychopath and and turned in my
understand for Katya and I booked it and
it was probably my second or third
audition ever as of as a as an actor and
and that was my first job and it changed
everything working with the team was
amazing it was so genuine and and you
know they really just wanted us to care
about this this person and it was my job
to make her live and breathe and
and to give her reasons to love her
hot-headed husband and reasons to hate
other things you know to be an actor but
because of that job I met some of my
closest friends to this day you know
Melissa Hutchison who's Clementine is
one of my best friends Owen Thomas who
is Omid in the series and Gavin Hammond
who's Kenny and you know we all met
after we had filmed after we'd recorded
this game and said oh my god you're
you're Clementine
I'm Katja can you believe they did this
to us oh it was crazy
but it was such a bonding experience
we're normally in games you could share
a hundred credits with someone and be
like oh yeah that was cool and it
doesn't really matter but this one was
just lightning in a bottle and and you
know also through that I met Shawn
Bannerman and jake rodman a rod Ken and
we went on to do a fire watch and you
know that game just changed everything
it changed everything
fire watch all came from the walking
dead
so I met Shawn and Jake as I mentioned
working on the walking dead
and Shawn reached out to me shortly
after season 1 had wrapped and he said
you know I've left telltale I'm writing
a new game with a female protagonist are
you in and as an actor that is the
greatest call to get and I said yeah of
course I said yes
and but it was you know a good two years
then until we actually kind of got down
to the Nitty Gritty of recording and of
course you know I went through the whole
range of emotion at that point if I god
have I been replaced have they found
someone else am I still in the running
is still gonna be me you know all the
self-doubt that we go through as actors
and they had me record a sample track
back when her name was Alice and and we
did you know kind of a test run for them
so that they could hear how I would be
as her and then they went through their
process of finding Henry which was for
them quite arduous they they auditioned
several people just didn't quite fit the
bill and and they couldn't find who they
wanted and then rich Sommer was talking
with one of the Camposanto guys on a
tabletop game Twitter feed and he was
like hey I'd like to audition and they
were like they're okay and he just
nailed it so from there we started
recording what they did which was so
wonderful as an actor was they let me be
in my home studio and rich was in his
home studio and Shawn would Skype us in
together and we would have actual
conversations actual dialogue which as
video game voice actors we typically
record and avoid and we might have a
director who knows what they're talking
about we might not but we never get to
interact with the other actors the other
characters in the scene and so to have
this game that really hinges upon
believable dialogue be a dialogue it was
game changing pun intended what I look
for in a character is something I can
really hold on to I loved
three-dimensional well-written
well-thought-out characters it's it's
really easy to write a flat character
damsel in distress or you know whatever
but I would I really gravitate towards
which I think shows in my resume are the
characters that are deeply flawed
somehow but they're never gonna tell you
how you know there's Joyce and life is
strange and and what happened to her to
get her to the point that she is at with
this man in her life and then you know
Delilah and and what did she go through
to get to where she's at and and Katya
even and I like finding the meat and
really digging into that which is not to
say that I won't do other characters cuz
we've all got bills to pay but I really
like finding well-rounded juicy
characters I think being able to pick
and choose projects is um it's a
double-edged sword if you're young and
you're hungry and you're just looking to
build a resume it's a it's harder to say
you want to pick and choose however I
think there are certain things we have a
social obligation to shy away from
people need to be cast racially
appropriately and if you can help it God
knows sometimes we get in the booth and
they're like by the way this character
is not white Oh
I think you know if there's if you have
a moral obligation to a company and you
don't want to do a commercial for them
don't do the commercial for them or do
the commercial and take the proceeds and
give it to charity I think it depends on
each person's station you know if
they're if they're in a place where
they're comfortable turning down work
great games in particular I think I
think there's enough work for everybody
my favorite thing about Delilah is that
the player has to decide how they feel
about her without knowing what she looks
like
they don't know if she's buxom they
don't know if she's beautiful they don't
know if she's x y&z they just have to
decide what conversations they want to
have with her based on how funny they
think she is or how how interesting they
think she is and that's so rare it's so
rare that we're unclouded by physical
appearance in in real life and in games
I am hopeful for the future of roles for
women in voiceover and I in video games
and I think it's it's evolving you know
you're seeing more female leads and
options for female leads and even you
know LGBTQ leads and and non-traditional
leads non-white you know I think it's
we're getting into a place where making
games is becoming more accessible for
smaller teams and they're able to tell
different stories with different voices
and I think that's just going to
proliferate more and more and I'm here
for it I am here for it well I think
with games you have an opportunity to
make a proper game with fewer people you
can't make a movie or a television show
with fewer than I don't even know how
many people but you know fire watch was
made with a team of eight I know people
who are making games solo one person
writing this entire game I'm making a
game with a friend of mine you know what
I mean so it's it's not gonna be
uncharted 4
but you know it's gonna be its own
experience and we have that option now
whereas in games in in movies and
television it still requires a full crew
which is not necessarily the case in
games
I would say the difference between
triple-a and Indy is that I have more of
a say in my character which is not to
say the triple A's aren't open to it but
usually it's gone through such a process
to get to where it's at that it's pretty
written in stone
whereas Indies it's a little more on the
fly
you know there's option for discussion
about certain things and and an input
where we have less interpolates my
inspirations there's a lot of them you
know in video games voiceover in general
is such a supportive community just so
many incredible people who really
legitimately want each other all of us
to succeed and I have been so graced
with Melissa Hutchison from The Walking
Dead and Jennifer Hale and Courtney
Taylor and Ashly Burch and all of these
generous loving people who who are
willing to help their friends and and
and that's been invaluable you know
commercially I met Marilyn Wissner early
on and she she kind of gave me the
confidence boost that I needed and
really believed in me and that meant
more than anything I met my agent before
I was anything and and he kind of pulled
me aside and said you've got it
so work on it and find me when it is
ready for public consumption and again
that confidence boost was was kind of
exactly what I needed at the moment I
want all the roles I I would love to do
a female bond I would love to do you
know Wonder Woman I I want all the
things I want all the things all of them
best thing about voice-over is I can be
anything I have been an 80 year old
woman I have been a 12 year old boy I've
been every manner of creature in between
it doesn't matter what I look like it
doesn't matter my age it just matters if
I can do it believably
and interestingly that's it that's the
secret sauce the worst thing if there is
a worst thing about voice-over is you
know it's a gig economy I could have a
great year one year and a terrible year
the next tonight I'm always hustling for
that
for that next paycheck so it's trying to
figure out where that's going to come
from how to keep it sustainable how do I
keep doing it while I get older Oh God
just going down that path
yeah I'd say but you know I'm happy
doing what I'm doing and I I will be
bagging groceries at the grocery store
before I go back to corporate
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]